at this year's star wars celebration
event in London we got to see a
behind-the-scenes look at the upcoming
standalone movie rogue one this video
was not a trailer yet with some
frame-by-frame dissection there were
definitely some new details about the
film that we can take away so let's get
right into the breakdown the first
combat shot of the video shows this guy
jumping down and when you compare this
to a later shot of alan tudyk who plays
the droid k2s oh he seems to be wearing
the same motion capture suit essentially
this guy jumping is probably going to be
the droid speaking of droids here we
have an RA 7 protocol droid foreseen in
a new hope these are deaths are droids
and we're typically given to Imperial
officers in this shot we have a few Mon
Calamari the same species as Admiral
Ackbar what's worth noting is that
what's now known as legend Canon the
Empire invaded the Mon Calamari planted
act subsequently enslaving a good amount
of the species perhaps this bit of laura
has been incorporated and the Mon
Calamari are ready to fight back work
Davis he's currently not listed in the
IMDb but this will mark his fourth
appearance and a Star Wars film the
first being the Ewok wicked a handful of
characters in The Phantom Menace
including walking shots as Yoda and a
wool oven and the force awakens in what
appears to be an assistant director
setting up an action scene we get an
interesting bit of information cools
down sounds like he's saying x-wing
kills the ad act AKA 8080 maybe this
means a squadron of x-wings swoop in and
save the day during that risky dash
regardless you can count on x-wing
showing up during whatever tropical
setting this is this quick shot of a
little girl is interesting if we really
want to speculate could this be gin or
so in a flashback or maybe the film
starts 10 years earlier where we uncover
the mystery of djinns father gallon who
has been very much covered up not much
revealed here other than the fact that
rogue one's costume department has a
destiny fan yeah based on the first
trailer it's safe to say at some point
we know Jin Urso disguises herself as an
imperial pilot and in these two shots we
now see that captain Anders is dressed
up as an imperial officer fighting
alongside her these two are clearly in
the process of infiltrating an imperial
base or even the Death Star
those are just a few moments I noticed
and this behind-the-scenes look at rogue
one if you have any details or thoughts
please put them in the comment section
below or send them my way on Twitter
thanks for watching may the force be
with us